i can't help myself from doing this
see era do people greet you like that
because you grew up in atlanta around
when sierra was coming up as
the sierra
yeah i mean my entire middle school high
school until now careers that's how i
get greeted on the regular but i kind of
love that for me
i was gonna say it there are worse ways
to be creative
yeah especially when the song comes on
in the club like i can look at my friend
and they're like the princess is here
yeah she is you get to have your little
moment all right yeah well we're not
here to talk about that sierra we're
here to talk about this sierra who
i already told you an affront to
thanksgiving you have a christmas tree
already up but i will let it be
i will let it be it's in the theme for
winter house we are in the thick of this
17 days in vermont that you lived months
ago having to relive now i spoke to you
i think like the week you got back to
new york from this experience yeah
oh my god you're so right you did wow
yeah and i have a little bit of a bone
to pick with you because i asked you
about austin the internet thinks you and
austin kroll are dating
no where are you okay i mean i thought
it was funny but
i'm not mad at it he's cute and you said
no nothing is happening which i
understand maybe in the present moment
of that interview nothing was happening
but something had happened while you
were at this house well honestly even in
the moment of that interview something
was still happening but i wasn't gonna
tell you
just not yet i mean like
everything was still like playing itself
out and like i mean i can't smell the
beans too early but
this is fair you gotta protect the bag
uh that comes along with this experience
yeah but on a scale of one to ten how
awkward is it to relive and re-watch
this romance that seemingly
didn't last very long
damn okay
um
there are moments where i am like
it is it's it's tough i still kind of
have like these feelings towards him so
it's even though like we're not dating
or anything for right now this is what's
best for both of us i'm not saying that
like the door is shut completely on at
100 so it's like
who knows but i think timing had a lot
to do with it i mean he was three months
post a relationship
and i was not
really even thinking like yeah we need
to leave this house and be in a
relationship so
you were having fun on vacation a hot
tub worked its magic and the rest is
history
the hot tub the snow
all the all the elements down
well let's unpack all of this because
people
were
and are very surprised by this coupling
even paige says in the trailer hold on
let me get this right
three girls fighting over austin kroll
just confused i've met austin i
understand the charismatic pull he has
but i there is something that gets lost
between the tv screen and the viewer so
can you explain to people who don't get
it what the appeal of austin kroll is
i mean he has such a big personality
he's loud he's rambunctious and like
initially didn't really like him i tell
him this all the time i was like i
thought you were just like way too much
but like he definitely grew on me in the
most positive way and then like i feel
like whenever you're filming with
someone it does speed up your
relationship and like you get to know
them like you get to know them on a
deeper level too and i feel like there
were so many moments where like i felt
like i could trust him and like feeling
safe and secure is something that's like
so important to me and i feel like he
always made me feel that way like with
everything that went down on and off
camera and that definitely like
catapulted like me
really liking him that
explains these really emotional moments
we get in the trailer of you saying yeah
you're scared to like yeah you know that
i like you i cried after our first date
because i am scared to like you explain
those feelings to me and why you were in
that head space was it just that all the
elements were there it is this
heightened version of reality it's a
compressed amount of time it's all of
everything that you just said it was
like you know
do i like someone who's also in the
public eye like that's also so new and
so scary because like i am kind of a
private person and i do want to like
hold on to a certain level of that and i
knew that he was like only a few months
out of a relationship so i was like i'm
scared to fully like you because like i
don't want to be hurt in the midst of
this and i like
don't want to feel like i can be my best
and true self with you and then
after we leave the house to be nothing
at all and i think it's important for
people to remember that you lived this
while you were just becoming a known
entity in the world summer house was
airing
right while you were making this show
so that's also a mind f in a sense yeah
it's still hard and i mean austin had
been in the game for a while and i had
not and like
that that just was like i don't know and
i wanted people to like really see that
like we liked each other and it wasn't
like this thing for tv like i genuinely
liked him and like yeah it wasn't
anything that was forced or produced or
yeah well we have
quite a few more weeks of this show to
watch and then i
you know assuming we've got a season of
another shuttle watch and then a season
of yet another show to watch um like
this whole universe is a domino effect
but
without
you can't i know you can't give
everything away but why do you think it
didn't translate outside the house into
something serious
i think timing logistics charleston
atlanta then i ended up moving to new
york you know
timing in terms of like he was not ready
for anything like that and honestly i
don't think i was either and i did go to
charleston
you know
and like we had a lot of fun there but
like i kind of knew i needed to take a
step back from it for a second and like
you know realize that we're not filming
we're not living together anymore and
like the dynamic is definitely going to
be different and you know
i was kind of in the mindset of like
whatever happens happens and like if we
cross paths again and like want to try
it again like okay but like for right
now it's
you know
you're in a in a friendly space right
now yeah well let's talk about the other
factor here lindsay hubbard okay
let's get this party started hobbs
house
she steps into the house
she creates a bit of a love triangle how
did lindsay coming into the house after
you'd had these couple days with austin
complicate things with him
i mean i just i feel like i was sold a
different version of the relationship
and honestly i wasn't privy to a lot of
what i've been seeing yeah i just did
not know and at that time i was never
upset with lindsay i never said anything
to her that was like negative and i
think that there were a lot of moments
where like she kind of like i could tell
that she had feelings towards me but
never said anything her reaction to
learning that you and austin were
exploring something has kind of been
whatever who cares which can't make you
feel good as a person
what do you mean like
because it's it makes it sound to me
like she's saying i don't care if she's
there i'm gonna pursue austin anyway
yeah
i think that's exactly what it is um
no comment
okay
so where do where do you and lindsay
stand now are you
how would you describe yourselves are
you friends acquaintances co-workers
i think we're cordial and friendly
there's been just like a lot of things
that have gone down just in terms of
winter house and summer house that it's
like it's hard to kind of
i mean i think like obviously we're not
filming anymore but like we definitely
need like space apart what did you make
of austin on watch what happens live
this isn't a much talked about episode
who is the better kisser oh man sierra
okay
i don't feel like he did anything that
was like rude
or he answered the questions that were
asked
right or disrespectful towards her i
don't feel like anything was targeted
towards her or
anything um i mean he answered the
questions how he felt like how he wanted
to and that like there's nothing wrong
with that i mean maybe some expectations
weren't met in that room and like you
can't
you can't cater to that all the time so
yeah she escaped an interview saying
she's taking a strong break from that
friendship at some point um
you know i i just i can't
like be okay with keeping that kind of
person in my life i don't need to train
a 34 year old man how to be a good
friend to me it's just like not in the
cards they've unfollowed each other on
instagram does any of that surprise you
but like if
she didn't feel like she was the better
cuddler or or whatever like
who ca like okay who cares like you
can't
like you want him to lie
like i don't
i i think that that's kind of crazy
i could take a knife right here and cut
the tension of while talking about
lindsay so i am very interested to see
how the rest of the season plays out how
summer house plays out um because it
seems like there will be a lot
yeah i think so too
last lindsay question what do you make
of this whole
lindsay carl maybe maybe not being a
thing
no comment truly
we are headed into episode four we are
getting
some conflict between paige and andrea
this is definitely the most romantic
thing i've ever done like i have to now
tell myself and like yeah you have to
that he's going around telling people
he's not into it you have to
did it surprise you to learn that maybe
his intentions weren't
the purest with paige
i mean
i mean i feel like i mean i've done the
whole
super fun hot model type of you know
thing else i just don't take them
seriously um male models and like yeah
he's hot he's italian like cool but like
he knows he's got plenty of options so i
just kind of like i love andrea but like
i did kind of feel like
boy energy
that he talks to
this is why i don't like sleep with
people i don't want to look stupid we
know paige lucked out out of all of this
she lands with craig
bravo sweetheart how do you feel about
this coupling
i mean
i
love paige and i love whoever paige
chooses and
i mean i do love craggy too like i mean
honestly it's very fun i feel like i'm
their child sometimes when it's like
three of us because i'm like okay mom
and dad and then their adopted child
like you know so
i i love them together they have a lot
of fun and they can just kind of like be
kids and like
be themselves and
i'm here for it did you feel more
comfortable
making a winter house than you did
summer house i definitely felt more
comfortable filming winter house i feel
like i feel like winter house was
definitely
more fun than like season five summer
house just because like i mean the
elements were on vacation like it wasn't
like where everyone's working and stuff
it was let's have fun and like fully
take advantage of vermont while we're
here because we're here for two weeks so
right it was 17 days but you guys packed
in
a lot i i've told everyone i've
interviewed from your cast so far that
this seems like the horniest show on
bravo ever um
i mean people are like oh my god that's
so fun i was like no but we're also
working like it's work like it's work to
drink 10 days 17 days in a row do you
think that's do you think that's easy no
that's what kyle and amanda were saying
it's like having to wake up and feeling
at your worst but knowing you need to
perform at your best is like quite
the feat
there were so many days where me and
paige would wake up and be like we're
not drinking tonight like we're just
gonna fake it we're not drinking and
then we take one shot two shot and we'd
be like
i mean we might as well we're already
here like let's just get drunk okay
you were trying to lie to yourselves and
you knew the truth your room looks a
little cleaner in winter house than it
did in summerhouse so far
i don't know if that's paige is doing or
what
we both had a very honest effort in
keeping the room clean but i just like
want everyone to know like can we pan
everyone's room
in the house because it doesn't look
great it's not great do people know for
a fact austin's room was a mess
do people like look where the cameras
are and shove stuff behind it like make
their best pile okay for sure
for sure
why were you and paige though sleeping
upside down on that bed your pillows are
always at the foot of the bed
okay like our bed broke and like
okay so we
it would be the four of us in bed like
me paige austin andrea and like it would
be like
like the head of the bed would slump
down we'd be in like a hole
and we were like is it because the guys
are so heavy but like then we'd wake up
it would just be me and her and we'd
wake up and we'd be in this hole so we
were like we're just gonna sleep at the
other end because like
i think there was no box spring on the
bed or something and it just kept
sinking but it was also so we could do
like weird things you couldn't see from
the camera
okay i love all these behind the scenes
secrets mystery solved somewhat i'm
excited to see how the rest of these i
think we got like 10 days or so left to
watch this adventure um plays out and i
will let you go live your christmas
fantasy in november
always the shade
[Music]